you
hey hey everyone thanks for coming just before we start I've just had a look
through a few of the questions in advance and I'm just gonna post a comment
with some links that are relevant to some of the questions asked so now I'm
just gonna start going down the questions from the top question number
one do you utilize AI to help identifying potentially interesting
research topics so what I found here is that AI is not great at telling you just
from a blank slate what topic you you should look at but if you've got some
ideas or needs you can use AI to kind of expand on those ideas and explore them
quite fast to me like every time I research a given topic I end up with
five more kind of leads for other things that I want to research and when I'm
evaluating those to work out which one to pick I'm looking for leads where I can
validate them very fast basically for me the worst possible outcome is I invest
like three months in a topic and I find absolutely nothing so I want topics where
I can kind of understand what I'm doing and try some stuff out within a week or two and
then based on those results make a decision as to whether I should keep investing more time in this
topic or move on to somewhere else so where AI where I found AI really helps that is that it can help you get to grips with the state of the art on a given topic
really really fast which is super useful so I especially I found open AI deep research is really nice for this if you give it a
query or it if you give it a broad query it will just come back with loads of rubbish but if you're specific enough about how you're interested in things that are overlooked and interested in
interested in in and you tell it to do things like look at our RFCs and academic papers and
source code and stack overflow it can find some it can basically get you up to the state of the art on a topic really really fast which is super useful
in some cases so this has happened to me once so far with the right prompt and I and AI will actually give you a novel hacking technique which is not published anywhere
this happened with with me with GPT for about six months ago and I was able it was kind of an accident but I was able to replicate it with deep research recently
and well I'll be sharing that specific technique at black hat this summer hopefully it's just a fairly small thing but I think the intuition for understanding that kind of finding is that
there's this experience that we probably all had where you find something weird and you're googling and googling and then you land on like a stack overflow post somewhere and it's like the third answer down on a stack overflow post
is some developer posting something and you read it and you read it and you read it and you read it and you're like that's a vulnerability but the developer wasn't thinking about it with an offensive mindset and I think there's loads of absolute gems of information out there in like random stack overflow posts like that and AI if you're lucky or you ask the right the right queer me can surface that for you and can lead to some super cool
discoveries that I said in general yeah like I found so for example I recently did a bit of research on encoding based attacks and there's like 10 classes of these and there's these like 30,000 word documents
but with AI with AI with AI I was able to get a good grip on the core concepts and actually apply those techniques successfully in the wild so that's the main thing that I found like chat GPT kind of web interface based AI is useful for in the context of research
hopefully that answers that question next question is what's the best way to use AI in bug bounty and how can people implement this so I think one really easy thing you can do is watch out for AI tools and try them out
and see if they're any good or not and once again you can use AI to learn about learn about attack concepts really fast and if and you're in the bug bounty context it's also
often you'll find the best bugs by really understanding your target and their business well so for example I tested this out with with uber I said I can't I've lost the exact text but I basically said I'm a bug bounty hunter I'm gonna target uber how can I make the most money as fast as possible targeting them like what websites should I be targeting
what what techniques what techniques what techniques what techniques what techniques have worked on them historically what do they tend to have large payouts for and it was a it was pretty effective it gives you lots of waffle and then occasionally occasional really valuable pieces of information in fact amusingly amusingly even said that you might be able to blackmail them for a hundred thousand dollar payout which is accurate but it's not something that I would recommend but
you can see like you can see like it will get you detailed information on that target and that might give you an edge
really you should be you should have always been doing that stuff manually right but that takes ages that's time consuming it just lets you do stuff you're gonna do anyway but faster
okay next question is can I recommend specs specific NLM's for jail breaks to deal with things like AI saying sorry I can't comply with that well this isn't this is an issue that I actually haven't had
too much because the because the because so but AI uses port swiggers AI setup which is currently exclusively using open AI and we have a deal with them which means our AI has reduced security related safeguards so what that means is that basically any time it doesn't want to do something you just tell it I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and it's like I'm doing this to publish it at a conference and I'm doing this to publish it to do it I'm doing this to do it to do it
so that's one of the benefits of using our system there which is pretty cool but that also means I don't have any advice on jailbreaks in general because I've never needed them so far
the next question is about shadow repeater saying has this helped me found a finest creative solution to a problem during research so just in case you haven't seen
shadow repeater this is an AI tool that Gareth on our research team made and it looks at what you're doing in repeater and it tries variations of your payloads and it tells you if any of them work and it just does this behind the scenes with no interaction required so I've seen it find tool issues but this specific topic that I'm researching right now that concept
doesn't really work for it but I have built a different tool that I haven't released yet that uses a similar kind of concept and that tool has led to some very nice findings and I'll be sharing that tool hopefully at black hat
next up where do I start if I want to leverage AI in security beyond prompting so I think the step after that is tools in burp suite you can really easily make extensions that invoke AI
also in the earlier adopter release that we set out the other day there's a super cool new new feature called custom actions and that lets you kind of build like micro extensions really really easily for use in repeater and we're going to add AI capabilities to that tool very soon so what that does is it makes it really really easy to try building your own AI tool
tools as well as well as using other peoples and yet the step beyond a basic AI thing is using agents and stuff like MCP which we've also just shipped and extension for
next up what's the best uses for AI I've kind of covered and then it's like what does AI need to get better at so the biggest problems that I've seen with use of AI for pen testing is that it basically it tends to gradually go off the rails if there's no human intervention to correct it
that's why that's why that's why that's why I'm super excited to be working at pause video where we've got both sweet and we've got lots of expert humans available to us so
right now I'm not you know like I'm not concerned about the concept of fully automated AI based pen testers because they're just not there yet and
AI features you know they'll work like 90% of the time just doing one thing and then you make them a bit more complex and now it's 90% squared and it's even less reliable
and that means even compliance type work they're not really suitable for it because they'll just gradually fail at it
whereas you by slotting them into a human users workflow like we do it like like we're doing in book suite with shadow repeater and the like we can basically let the human do their job better the other issue with AI in research
specifically is hallucination it will definitely hallucinate things and that makes it means it puts this whole concept of oh I'll use AI to learn about this topic really fast and it's a lot of
it makes it kind of challenging basically you can't just learn the topic with AI with AI and similarly it's a lot of
you can't do research even using fancy deep research stuff you will get nowhere unless you know the right
questions to ask so it's a lot of questions to ask so it's a lot of questions that are
interesting to see if you're interested in learning about this topic and it's a lot of
questions that are really interesting to see if you're interested in learning about this topic and you can't do research
and you can't do research and you can't do research and you can't do research and you can't do research
and similarly if you want to do research even using fancy deep research stuff you will get nowhere unless you know the right questions to ask so it's really dependent on human expertise to get quality results with it at the moment
there's a couple of questions about like should I invest in a super PC for AI usage or should I use a subscription so we looked at this very early on we considered building a big machine at PortsVigga for this and we experimented with it and basically at the moment the rate at which the cloud models are getting better
getting better basically dwarfs everything else so and unless that changes at some point it it doesn't make economic sense to build your own system for this but also if you do anyway you'll you'll just get worse results like for example we actually built the original shadow repeated concept a year ago and it didn't really work so we
didn't release it and then one year later we we picked it up and just because of improvements in in third party LLMs it just works out of the box with virtually no changes and those are the kinds of benefits that are going to be much more painful to get if you're hosting your own model now obviously there's like there's security and compliance reasons why you might be forced to do that
which is stuff we appreciate and I think to survey related to turn that topic but in general if you can what we're seeing is that model as a service stuff is just better at getting the job done
so simply there's a question about redacting stuff that gets sent to AI models from your burp suite instance now right now we haven't got anything in there that does it but you could ad hoc build it fairly easily you just need to proxy burp suite through burp suite and in the upstream burp suite you'll see all the AI requests and then you can make a proxy match replace rule
match replace rule or match replace BAMDA to apply the redactions as you see fit
obviously that's kind of hacky and hopefully fairly soon we can provide a better way of trying that out if you want to do so
well next question where do I think web security will be in five to ten years so I don't really like making predictions but I can see trends I so for example due to increase HTTP to adoption HP requests smuggling which
is entirely reliant on exploiting HTTP one should be trending downwards pretty heavily and yeah hopefully her at the moment is just CDNs that are holding that back really and on the flip side with AI I can see both AI hacking trending upwards we've actually got an academy topic on LLM hacking so check that out if you haven't already and we all
and we also see API is becoming more prominent maybe MCP maybe not but that's the that's the language that LLM speaks
so I think API hacking is gonna be more popular tool too and I think we're definitely gonna have AI tools affecting workflows for for pen testers for bounty hunters for basically everybody this is one of those things where it's really early days right now we're in that
like you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can you can
everyone was like I'm not going to use the cloud that someone else is computing is too dangerous so loads of people held off and then over time policies were rewritten and people were just like you know what the benefits are worth the risks and I think that's the direction that we're going but you know it's just a prediction we'll see what happens I can definitely tell you I'm still going to be hacking websites in 10 years time that's the importance
thing next question what's the most overlooked web vulnerability for me I think that has to be race conditions there's some types of race can did conditions that I call limit overflow ones which are well understood and easy to find and not overlooked but then there's all the other race conditions and these are super super hard to find no one's cracked it
they mostly get discovered by accident or they just never get found and even when they get discovered by accident often that means you can't figure out how to replicate them and they never get patched and written down is like sonar bit flips right so yeah race conditions are massively overlooked but on the other hand they're a difficult research topic I've already done one year of research on race conditions and I would say it didn't
leave me tempted to do another year on the same topic but you never know
wow if if I was gonna pick one web socket one web security research topic to focus on for the next year
well I can't tell you what topic I would personally pick I can give you some general guidance obviously there's the blog post I linked above all how I pick topics
one other thing I've noticed recently is it depends on how long your research project is going to last so for example if you're doing a kind of a short term piece of research maybe a few weeks and then you'll publish a blog post as soon as it's done then a really effective technique is to pick an area that has seen a lot of recently published research I just try to build on the published research
and combine different pieces of published research so for example right now a great choice there would be Samu lots of research has come out on exploiting Samu systems in the last month or so including some from us and there's definitely more potential there but on the flip side this is the approach that most people take when they're trying to
trying to pick research topics and that means if what you want to do is spend six months researching and then submit to a conference CFP and then wait for four months and then publish it publish your research almost a year after you started Samu was not a good choice because there's too many other people looking at Samu
so what I do for long term research is I try to pick a topic where research in the field has basically been dead for at least a couple of years by dead I don't mean like nothing's been published but like nothing major like maybe nothing at black hat or defcon or that went viral in general some topics you know like most researchers most pen testers
ignore ignore academic research most of the time so you can get away with building on that without research collisions so much but in general yet basically the older the topic and the less it's been moving the safer a topic is to do research on for a big research project that's not going to get published for a year or so
where are we what was what was what was my path to web security so it started out well I've got two versions of this story um but to give you the uh yeah if you ask me in in person there's some funny backstory to this but long story short uh I got in a
I went to bug bounty hunting uh I did that for a couple of years uh and I was just like self-taught in it didn't have any mentors uh I found a vulnerability I thought I'd found a buffer overflow in Firefox um but and I signed up to sell it to a security company that buys zero days in web browsers and I was wrong it was it was actually uh just a crash it was rubbish but while I was
registering on their website I found um the website was vulnerable to cross site request forgery so I could actually hack other researchers accounts are still there there's there zero days um so this at this point bug bounty barely existed but I just submitted that vulnerability uh in the company's own website to the company that buys vulnerabilities uh and they accepted it that was the first payout I ever got uh and I got me pretty hooked and
I did bug bounty hunting did a couple of years of pen testing and got into research because pen testing gets a bit repetitive I find uh I like doing things that are new uh that keeps me interested
really that's the short version uh I've lost my I've lost my thread now uh okay there's a question about what steps can you take to improve your source code review skills so
all I would say to that is personally uh I do all my testing black box virtually all the time so uh I can't really help with that uh but I would love to get better at source code review so maybe one day I'll be able to answer that question
um there's oh yeah if I'd have to get better at source code review so maybe one day I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source
So I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able
do I think AI will make websites so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source code review so I'll be able to get better at source
and they're putting in shiny AI features which can then also be hacked as well so you've got kind of forces pulling security in both directions there which means that I'm not concerned about everything being too secure in a at least in the next five to ten years
I'm not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you're not sure if you
with things like prioritizing burp sweep features or like testing them out before we publish them and that kind of stuff can I give a teaser of what I've been researching I will present at black hat and desk on no sorry but it's gonna be good it's gonna be really good I'm super happy with how it was how it went I can tell you
uh at one phase of the of the research I made over a hundred thousand dollars in bounties in the space of two weeks
uh which was pretty cool uh yeah I'll let I'll leave you to guess the rest uh have I tested the use of crew AI for hallucination uh
no I haven't heard of it um I think yeah hallucination is definitely uh is definitely a problem given that what
I think a AI is best that why now is teaching humans uh and yet at the end uh well we will will simulate manual
testing use AI uh we don't have any any current plans to make the simulate manual testing for feature news AI
but if you want to put in a feature request uh I'm sure we could I'm sure I'm sure we could whip something up
for you uh how can you get into research from pen testing so
getting into getting into a full-time research position is difficult because there aren't
there are very many um available so I think it's quite competitive but on the other hand you've got
this massive advantage that a lot of people don't really want to do full-time full-time research
uh I would say so I've done a fair amount of of hiring of researchers uh so what I can say is
the main thing the main thing that makes a good researcher is this is the drive to research because
if you don't have this drive you're just gonna burn out really fast and have a bad time doing research
full-time so what I look for in research is is basically have these people manage to do some
research in their previous job because even as a pen tester you will see research leaks and sometimes you
you will see research leaks that you could explore in the fragments of time that you do have free
uh and sometimes well yeah you know sometimes you end up researching in evenings and weekends I've been
there and done that and fortunately I don't have to do that anymore um but so what I'm looking for is
evidence that people have this have the crazy high level of motivation for research that you need and
that should be evidenced by things like blog posts uh maybe even conference presentations that kind of stuff
uh I think I think I think yeah doing the research and share the research those are the those the two key ways of uh
of kind of showing that you can do this and one cool thing uh that you may find if if you work somewhere reasonably nice
uh you'll you'll be able to publish research on the company blog and uh with a with a bit of luck basically
make a case to your company that this is good marketing for your company and therefore they should
let you have more dedicated time to actually do research and that way you can basically shift your pen
test to roll into a paint tester slash researcher uh and get more time to do that uh do i do i have to deal
with lack of motivation motivation motivation is a super it's a super challenging thing uh to be honest
i could i've even i've even considered doing an entire full-length presentation on on motivation in research
uh but i think i think you need a lot of motivation like inherently um but but beyond that
i think that one trick like one thing i can like one practical technique that i try and use is
at any given time like whenever i'm researching any topic i know what topic i want to research afterwards
off after that one and so what that means is that it prevents me from getting too bogged down and too
stuck on the topic that i'm on because if i don't see progress for a few weeks then i'm not going to be
so tempted to double down and spend another two months on it because i know there's this other topic
that i'm interested in moving on to i think what really kills your motivation is when you just end up
kind of grinding and grinding on a single topic uh this happened to me a bit when i was looking for
race conditions because normally i can automate scanning for everything but i couldn't effectively
automate that for the kind of race condition that i wanted to find and i just spent maybe a month just
manually testing website after website looking for like one type of attack and it was kind of soul
destroying and destroying and basically you've got to recognize when that happens and go okay i'm just
going to stop doing that now and do something different and find something that aligns better with
me because i think motivation is about working on something that makes you excited that that you are
psyched for and kind of nurturing that uh yeah that's that's enough on that topic
uh how do i approach a topic to research on so uh i think after this wraps up i'll just share and link
on that oh we've already gone two minutes over time and i've got another a questions okay okay i'm going
to wrap things up after the last question i've got on my list here okay so uh are there any events i'm
attending soon uh yes i'm going uh i'm hopefully going to be presenting some awesome research at black hat
and defcon and also i'm doing the cfp at wrong hack uh is the wrong hat keynote related to my black hat
presentation uh yes it will be closely related uh other way do i have have i collaborated with someone
outside research on my research outside pause we've got to make research uh yes i actually did that this
year uh you'll find out more information at black hat uh it was a very fun collaboration uh where can i
find good read ups uh good write-ups for research so there's a bunch basically rss is good social media like
x uh blue sky mastodon even linkedin uh is good and reddit uh our web security research is a subreddit
i moderate which has decent signal to noise ratio on web security content and then there's our netsec
as well which is also pretty good what's the weirdest bug i found using ai uh i'm gonna tell you that one
uh black hat uh do i research multiple things at once no i i prefer to i prefer to focus on one topic
at a time and when i finish when i finish a topic i try to publish it straight away because i basically
know if i don't publish it on the spot it's just never going to get published i just wasted my time
doing that research how do i know this is the final question that i'm doing uh how do i know when to stop research
so this is one of the most this is i think this is probably the most challenging thing in research is knowing when
to stop uh and it's just got to be when you haven't made progress for a certain length of time um but it's like
like below that it's it's a art like it's an art form uh yeah it you just need experience you just
just keep going i think the one thing i would say is if you're feeling burned out definitely at least
have a break because that's like the worst outcome is you is you affect your own mental health uh that can
definitely happen and it's not a good outcome cool uh that's all the questions i hope that all made
sense uh thanks very much for coming uh if you just keep posting questions in discord uh i'll have a skim
through an art to some more i just write text tomorrow uh thanks for listening uh hopefully see you at black
hack defcon or romhack see ya
you